- You know I love Meryl Streep,
you like make out with her.
- Well I,
you'll have to see the movie.
- I did see it,
you kissed her,
(laughing)
I did see it and you kissed her
and I was like and first of all,
I'm upset at how beautiful she is.
I'm like good God
- Yeah.
- woman
- Yeah,
she's beautiful.
- and her that little red,
little short, I was like, are you serious?
- I know, look at her.
Look at her.
- I know, it's so upsetting.
(laughing)
Like, I'm like, you can't be
this talented and beautiful
and all the things and sing and,
but you, so you made out with Meryl.
- So, so here's what, here's the thing,
you know, stage kisses are,
can be awkward thing.
- Awkward.
Right?
And so my wife Elle, who is a director,
so a director and a
producer, she was like,
I think maybe it'd be a good
idea if we rehearsed the kiss,
you're gonna be kissing Meryl Streep.
- You don't want to suck.
- And you don't want, yeah,
you want to make sure that you do this as,
as well as you possibly can.
So we kind of choreographed
what I would do.
There was totally,
here's what I did, Kelly.
It was like, my wife's like,
so what you need to do
is you got to kind of go,
what was the kind of corsage you want?
Oh, a gardenia, sounds great.
You get a one, two step.
Then you got to boo, boom, dashing.
- Pull back, yes.
- And you go right into the,
and you go right into the kiss.
- It was hot.
- There's no stop, wait, kiss.
- No.
- You want to pull it, what?
Pivot and go into the kiss.
- Yup.
- And so--
- I call that the tension pivot.
- The tension.
(laughing)
- The tension pivot, yes.
- The tension pivot.
- You need just enough tension to be like.
(screaming)
- And I'm just going,
and I've never done like a dip kiss,
like what, those,
- Yeah.
- you know, so that was core
- and you got to get your,
you got to activate the core
- I'm out.
- and boom, and then dip, you know,
and then shablow, you know.
So my wife and I practiced like,
oh 50 times maybe,
60 times.
- Yes.
- And, and then, you know,
and then, and then we
took a break, had dinner,
couple more practice, I just
wanted to get it right guys.
I just really wanted to get it right.
- You did, I--
- So.
- How many takes?
That's awkward, is it like a lot of takes?
- It wasn't,
- Oh okay.
- it wasn't, it wasn't.
It was like, it was like
three or four.
- Oh, okay.
- Like three or four takes,
yeah.
- Three or four takes
of you to kiss Meryl Streep, what?
Big winner!
(laughing)